they cannot believe that finally we have
a republican politician who's doing the
right thing facing down the machine
facing down his opponents in the party
out of the party facing down the media
the whole freaking thing so across the
board they're going after him here is
race huckster Al Sharpton over the
weekend this is at Jordan Neely's
funeral
and I kept her as a minister deal with
this I heard the governor Florida
DeSantis
say that the man that killed Jordan
Was a Good Samaritan
well and they've raised over two million
dollars for this man
well I know Governor DeSantis
that you put in black history and lgbtq
in Latino out of the school
but I have a Bible to put in the
governor's office
[Applause]
because apparently you don't know
what the Good Samaritan was look he is
he is the worst sort of race hux there
if there is a wound in America that this
guy can rip open and pour salt on he
will always find it as you guys know
Governor DeSantis did not ban black
history or anything related to LGBT
except he can't mutilate kids sorry and
certainly nothing but he mentions the
Hispanic Community what DeSantis did
related to Black History was there was
one AP course one AP African-American
studies course which was also going to
teach gender queer Theory so as I've
said many times unless you think that
the Underground Railroad was being run
by a lesbian and you think that would be
important to teach even if she was this
is completely ridiculous black people
like everyone else are flourishing in
Florida
thank you
[Music]